switch gears and talk football the
coronavirus has forced the nfl to move
sunday's las vegas raiders game
member league officials they moved the
game it was supposed to be at five
o'clock at legion stadium on sunday
night now it's going to be one o'clock
sunday afternoon still at a legion
the nfl didn't want the prime time slot
empty if the game was canceled
that cancellation was into the
discussion because raiders offensive
tackle trent brown was put on the covid
reserve list with a positive test
several other players on the raiders
were held out of practice this week as a
precaution
at the end of the day we all knew that
it was going to be some some
some ups and some downs and you know had
to deal with a bit of bs you know i mean
while you're going into the season but
you know as far as just the game this
pattern you know we can we can line up
and play tomorrow it don't really matter
to us you know what i mean in the day we
love our guys we trust in the guys we
got here
regardless of whether you know those
five guys play or not
you know don't really matter to us you
know so we're gonna be ready regardless
now team is gonna make sure you are
ready for all things raiders this
weekend or should i say
greatest be sure to catch the raiders
pregame live program right here on
channel 8 starts at 8 o'clock sunday
morning
we hope you will join us